we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness this is an excerpt of the
us declaration of independence and the
united states goes on with its
constitution which gets ratified in 1789
to articulate a bill of rights and many
will point to the enlightenment as the
inspiration for these ideas thomas
jefferson who wrote the declaration of
independence cited figures like locke as
some of mankind's best thinkers so at
this early date nations were at least
writing these types of words into their
declarations of independence into their
constitutions but despite that
the 20th century is one of the bloodiest
centuries in human history
you have world war one where roughly 17
million people die
in world war ii 50 to 80 million people
die some directly because of the
conflict but many because of lack of
access to food and famine the chinese
are particularly hit over 15 million die
during the japanese occupation of china
this idea of genocide comes about
first with the armenian genocide in the
declining ottoman empire where over a
million people are believed to have been
killed and then in world war ii you have
the holocaust where six to 11 million
people were killed roughly two-thirds of
the jewish population in europe and many
others the russian empire and eventually
the soviet union gets especially hit
hard in the first half of the 20th
century
in world war one alone three million
russians die shortly after the war you
have a significant russian famine that
killed 5 million people
then in the early 30s you have the
soviet famine 5 to 7 million people this
is believed to have occurred because of
stalin's attempts to make agriculture
collectivized in the late 30s you have
stalin's purge where he goes after
political opponents and it's believed
that he killed as many as three million
people these things were so shocking to
the planet that they made attempts to
prevent them in the future
in 1920 out of the trauma of world war
one the league of nations was founded it
was an attempt to prevent things like
this in the future for nations to talk
to each other and to coordinate so they
don't go to war especially at the scale
seen in world war one
but clearly that was unsuccessful
and we have world war ii where even more
people die after which the slightly
stronger united nations gets founded
once again with the charter of fostering
dialogue between nations so that we can
prevent these types of trauma for the
planet early on in the newly founded u.n
agenda was this idea of revisiting the
ideas of the enlightenment this idea of
human rights and trying to codify them
in international law
in
1948 you have the universal declaration
of human rights that's drafted by the
united nations and it was an attempt to
make a universal declaration of these
rights that all humans on the planet
have access to i'm going to give
excerpts of it and keep a lookout for
things that feel awfully close to ideas
in the united states declaration of
independence the u.s constitution or
ideas from the enlightenment
this is part of the preamble whereas
recognition of the inherent dignity and
of the equal and inalienable rights of
all members of the human family is the
foundation of freedom justice and peace
in the world whereas disregard and
contempt for human rights have resulted
in barbarous acts which have outraged
the conscience of mankind remember world
war ii just happened and the advent of a
world in which human beings shall enjoy
freedom of speech and belief and freedom
from fear and want as has been
proclaimed as the highest aspiration of
the common people
now
therefore the general assembly proclaims
this universal declaration of human
rights as a common standard of
achievement for all peoples and all
nations you might be thinking why do
they even have to write this well think
about it things like the constitutions
of various countries especially the
united states these only applied to
those countries but now there was an
attempt to write down to codify
something that would apply to all human
beings to the entire planet
and here's just some of the 30 articles
to that declaration to that universal
declaration of human rights
all human beings are born free and equal
in dignity and rights they are endowed
with reason and conscience and should
act towards one another in a spirit of
brotherhood this really feels similar to
some of the ideas of locke in the
enlightenment that we talk about in
other videos everyone is entitled to all
the rights and freedoms set forth in
this declaration without distinction of
any kind such as race color sex language
religion political or other opinion
national or social origin property birth
or other status so this is interesting
because even though i start this video
with the united states declaration of
independence and a discussion of the
constitution slavery in the united
states would last for another 80 plus
years after the declaration of
independence was written women didn't
even have the right to vote until the
early 20th century so beyond this being
a universal declaration for the entire
planet the attempt is also to make it
clear that it needs to apply to everyone
everyone has the right to life liberty
and security of person
no one shall be held in slavery or
servitude
no one shall be subjected to torture or
to cruel inhuman or degrading treatment
or punishment
everyone charged with a penal offence
has the right to be presumed innocent
until proved guilty once again ideas
that seem very similar to what we see in
constitutions like that of the united
states
everyone has the right to freedom of
thought conscience and
religion everyone has the right to
freedom of opinion and expression very
similar to the first amendment in the us
constitution
everyone has the right to freedom of
peaceful assembly and association
no one may be compelled to belong to an
association
and article 21 is especially interesting
everyone has the right to take part in
the government of his country directly
or through freely chosen representatives
everyone has the right of equal access
to public service in his country the
will of the people shall be the basis of
the authority of government so this is a
big statement it's taking a stand saying
that everyone on the planet should be
able to live in a democracy and
participate in a democracy
the commission that drafted this
declaration was chaired by eleanor
roosevelt wife of franklin roosevelt
this is a map of who voted for this
declaration and these are the countries
in green who abstained they just decided
not to vote for the declaration those
are the countries in orange and then you
have a few that voted against it in gray
are the countries that weren't part of
the united nations at the time
an interesting question looking at this
map is to think about why certain
countries were willing to vote for it
and why other countries decided to
abstain at the time these articles are
talking about people having the right to
participate in a democracy the right to
be equal that all people are equal and
in many of these countries people did
not have equal rights you had severe
discrimination in places like south
africa in many of these countries you
did not have a democracy but there's a
broader question here
it's nice to be able to write these
fairly idealistic ideas but to what
degree does it have an effect and to
what degree can it actually be enforced
you might cite things like the american
civil rights movement which did echo
some of these ideas that were made in
the universal declaration of human
rights
maybe they helped the civil rights
movement or maybe the civil rights
movement would have happened regardless
of what the un did
but at the same time you have ideas like
apartheid you had racism and
discrimination in south africa from the
beginning of colonial rule but it was
actually at the exact same time as this
declaration that the official policy of
apartheid of government sanctioned
discrimination of government-sanctioned
segregation preventing racial mingling
came into effect and lasted all the way
until
1991.
and so one could make an argument maybe
things would have been worse without the
universal declaration of human rights or
maybe the universal declaration of human
rights really wasn't in a situation to
actually affect things like this in many
of the countries around the world not
just the orange ones but often in many
of the green ones as well you continue
to see things that go against those
ideas of universal human rights even if
the u.n passes something and if one
country doesn't want to abide by it what
action can the other countries take
economic action may be sanctions maybe
military action and to what degree are
people actually willing to do that